[Music]
put it on my tab Bonnie you got 410 we
were gonna do as the first episode when
it was like maybe three or four rewrites
to figure out and then once we figured
out that sort of noir tone then I kind
of started coming together
you know like it's almost the
first time that we see I mean a lot to
have any retention because we love just
having two characters that are
unconditional friends that are women but
this was the first time that we allowed
them to have that tension what was the
forgetting something really important
about the relationship great thank you
so much okay you met not mad just
informed like for Alana in the episode
it's hard for her not to take it
personal but it's like it's all there
like you don't really need this
anniversary to say what good friends we
are you're my everything
I was the horse me years about LeAnn
okay there is this Easter egg of a joke
that is like one of my favorite jokes in
10 when we watch this is liquid dumb
this thing in down when we walk into
this karaoke bar to follow this guy
there's a man singing a song that's God
Leah
[Applause]
it is a song that we made up and our
music supervisor Matt effects produced
[Music]
oh my god
and it plays throughout the entire
season on the radio in cabs it plays
throughout the entire smush room so when
Abby's like changing the music I'm like
nervous it goes yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
well it's just like what's the the pop
song and it's playing everywhere I am
[Music]
Hey